es gab allerdings heute auch regen und
ein echtes
wetterphänomene kasten wir holen mal
unseren reporter gerd schröder dazu der
steht in niedersachsen gerät und ja du
hast da an eine eine monster wolke
gesehen heute
genau es war also brütend heiß heute
auch hier im nordwesten in niedersachsen
und dann zog eine kleine aber sehr
heftige gewitter wolke hier über eine so
genannte cloud die sehr geballt war und
dann war auch im grunde klar gleich wird
es dort sehr sehr heftig bühnen und auch
regen geben und das war auch der fall
ist hat in einem bereich mehrere bäume
umgeworfen auf eine bundesstraße autos
waren dort eingeschlossen von den bäumen
es waren irgendwie gleich acht große
eichen die auch voll belaubt waren um
geflogen und das war ein sehr sehr
örtliches phänomen hier mittag grund bin
ich jetzt in ganderkesee dort ist eine
große eiche entwurzelt worden und auf
ein fachwerkhaus gestürzt und ja eine
wirklich 100 jahre alte eiche aber der
boden ist hier auch wirklich so trocken
dass das wurzelwerk hier auch im boden
nicht mehr hält und dann kommen diese
bühnen zu und schon stürzt so ein baum
hier auf das haus ja wir wollen nochmal
den kasten da zu gast die wolke die man
da gesehen hat das sieht fast aus wie
ein wal der ein riesiges maul hat da und
die und die landschaft verschlingt was
ist das für ein phänomen also
glückwunsch für diese aufnahme
wunderschönes foto das muss eigentlich
in unserer metro logischen kalender es
ist so dass das hier zwei aufwinde
aufeinandertreffen also auf finde aus
für diese gewitterwolke feucht-warme
luft die aufsteigt auf der anderen seite
fällt dann außerhalb dieser
gewitterwolke die luft herunter aus
großen höhen und beides zusammen gibt
dieses faszinierende schauspiel und man
sieht wenn man hier dieses foto sich
anschaut dieses diese zerfetzen da in
der wolke tritt das sind die böen die
dann über das land peitschen ja und die
dann leider denn die bäume dann
erwischen da können dann an so nah wie
anwohner bühnen walze durchaus 80 90 100
stundenkilometer auftreten und da kommt
jetzt die trockenheit wieder ins spiel
diese extreme trockenheit schwächt die
bäume da ist kein wasser mehr dann in
den ästen in den stämmen drin und die
knicken dann zum teil weg also da kommen
mehrere kindern zusammen aber
faszinierendes bild mit dramatischen
folgen
dramatische folgen gerne hätten noch mal
wir haben die leute das wahrgenommen und
dort bei der
ja die familie die hier in dem
fachwerkhaus lebte die hat im grunde
dieses unwetter gar nicht kommen sehen
und auch gar nicht kommen hören es war
wirklich sehr sehr schnell sie hörten
einen lauten knall dachten erst an ein
überschallflugzeug und plötzlich sagen
sie halt laub vor ihrem fenster wustlich
hingehört und guckte raus und sagen dann
dass die bescherung dass der große baum
auf dem haus liegt ist ein oben
dachbalken zerstört das dach ist so ein
dachpfannen zerstört und das thw im
hintergrund ist jetzt im einsatz um
diesen baum abzutragen und zwar unter
großer vorsicht damit eben nicht noch
mehr schäden hier geschehen am haus das
wird sehr vorsichtig abgetragen und ja
die anwohner waren wirklich überrascht
darüber es war zwar ein gewitter
angekündigt aber so heftig und so
schnell das hat die hier auch überrascht
[Musik]